I'm in a unique position to have a level
of influence on my community and what I
post does not mean that I support
everything that's being said or
everything that's being done or I'm
campaigning for anything all I do is
post things for my people in my
community and those that it's actually
going to impact
anybody else that has criticism and
obviously wasn't meant for them I am no
different than the next human being so
don't treat me any different
you guys come in here and make up this
powerful influence I have over top of
the adultery of all you you cannot post
that why not why did you decide to
promote something that Alex Jones said
that was a few weeks ago I do not stand
with Alex Jones
position narrative
court case study had with Sandy Hook or
any of the kids that felt like they had
to relive trauma or parents that had to
relive trauma or to be dismissive to all
the lives that were lost during that
tragic event
my my post was a post from Alex Jones
that he did in the early 90s or late 90s
about secret societies in America of
occults and it's true so I wasn't
identifying with anything of being a
campaign and a campaignist for Alex
Jones or anything I'm just there to post
and it's funny
and it's actually hilarious because out
of all the things I posted that day that
was the moment post that everyone chose
to
chose to see it just goes back to the
way our world is and works I'm not here
to complain about it I just exist
and to follow up on the promotion of the
movie in the book can you please stop
calling her a promotion what am I
promoting
put it out on your platform but I'm
promoting it do you see me doing do you
see in front of it out there people are
going to say that you are put it out
there just like you put things out there
right yeah but I okay you put things out
there for a living right right but my
stuff right so let's move on let's move
on anti-semitic let's move on don't
dehumanize me up here I'm not I'm not
doing that post whatever I want so say
that and shut it down and move on to the
next question but Kyrie you have to
understand that but I don't have to
understand anything from you no it's not
me nothing
bro move on but by posting come on next
question any questions do you guys have
any more questions and they're gonna say
you guys have any more questions
this is going to be a clip that he's
going to Marvel at is this any more
questions but you're not answering the
question there's another answering your
question oh my god let's make another
Instagram clip so we could be famous
again next question
that in exchange with Nick fardell the
other night after the game and
look if he's
he keeps making a big
thing out of the word promotion that is
promotion if if on your social media you
say boom here's a link to this
that tells me hey you should watch this
correct you're I mean he's got 17
million Instagram followers another five
million or so on Twitter you're all over
social media do you ever put something
out there Shaq that does not represent
something that you feel I was probably
one of the first guys on Twitter and
when I realized the power it had I knew
I had to be very responsible followers
platform whatever you call I knew I had
to be responsible
I I try to make people happy I try to
make people's my mom my formula has
always been the same 60 to make you
laugh 30 to inspire you and ten percent
whatever I'm selling I'm selling you
have to be
have to be aware of what you're doing
and you have to be aware that sometimes
when you put stuff out not everybody's
gonna like it
some some people are conscious some
people are not I could tell he's not
conscious he doesn't really care with
what's going on but us I know that that
you know the game that we used to love
and we promote it brings people together
and it hurts me sometimes when we have
to sit up here to talk about stuff that
divides the game now now we got to
answer for what this idiot has done uh
you know I'm I stand for equality of all
people I've always liked it don't matter
what religion no matter where you're
from I could say shalom salaam alaikum
Nihao sabon because that's how I was
raised so I don't really want to sit up
here and answer questions for what he's
done you know if you're looking at me
it's my job to make people happy I I
can't speak for him and you know answer
vote for you know what he's doing it's
obviously by his answers and the way he
answered he doesn't really care sure
I think the NBA dropped the ball
in what way I think he should have been
suspended
I think Adam should have suspended him
first of all Adam's Jewish
you can't take my 40 million dollars and
insult my religion you're going to
insult me
you have the right but I have the right
to say no you're not going to take my 40
million dollars and insult my religion I
think the NBA they made a mistake we
have suspended people to find people who
have made homophobic slurs
and that that was the right thing to do
I think if you insult the black
community you should be suspended or
find heavily dependent I saw they did
the same thing to the kid in Minnesota
this year when he made the gay slur I
think you should get suspended of fine
I think
him acknowledging The Alex Jones things
should have something should have
happened with that too because that
dude's crazy
and
I I can't believe that we ain't talking
about that we're talking about this
idiot and
when you say when you
if I say hey I'm agreeing with this move
or this book or whatever I'm agreeing
with it I'm not going to put first of
all you know I don't do any social media
but when you're somebody as great as
basketball like him
people going to listen to you what you
say and then you and there's some French
people out there but like I say I blame
the NBA he should have been suspended
and their conversations are continuing
with the Brooklyn Nets between the NBA
but they're also looking at look they're
looking now how do we move forward it's
too late now no it's not too late to say
how do we prevent it it's not too late
I want to say the reason is too late
the NBA is giving in to peer pressure
when if somebody if one of our players
do something they have the right the
team
or the or the league has to do something
immediately if you just get give in to
peer pressure that's the problem I have
this should have been handled already
Kenny let's get into this go ahead well
firstly
um
if we're going to take what he says
on a Twitter we have to take everything
he says so if I'm going to take
everything he says I'm going to believe
that he doesn't support or any of the
views or promote the reviews of it he
said it right in my face I have to
accept that so I will believe that there
are people in this world who's done in
in their art have done great things that
have said crazy things that we still
listen to their music we buy their
paintings we do their things and you
might take an episode of that and say I
believe in this okay so I'll take that
as it made from Kyrie Irving but I also
believe that the reporter did have a
right to ask the question sure that's it
so and that that's really where the
argument became do I have a you don't
have a right to ask me that question I
do believe that and based on this for
Kyrie is that he has put himself as he
says I'm the voice for some of the
speechless we're doing the covet so now
he has transcended from basketball and
became an activist politically so he you
will ask him that question based on some
things that you may read but I have to
believe leave him also when he tells me
that is if I'm going to believe parts of
it I have to believe the totality you
know what and
I just think
Kyrie's just part of this I mean
I just think we've lost our way I I
think I think in this country we've lost
our way I think I think people have have
forgotten what it's like to put the
thought process into if I if I put this
out there who am I going to hurt
giving no thought to that where's
where's civility these days uh where's
empathy but and and it's just and it's
it's a worrisome Road and it's a
dangerous road that we find ourselves on